okay we've been talking about this Jenga
board Jenga tower that is on the studio
desk with me and I'm going to get my
coffee cup out of the way here because
we are now going to start doing the
Jenga thing and what we've the idea here
is the following for every two patreon
contributors I will be moving a piece I
will be playing a piece of the Jenga
tower and eventually the Jenga tower
will fall and when we when it does fall
we will double the number of moves that
I'm able to make and create a membership
coupon code with that percentage
discount if I'm able to move 20 pieces
we will create a 40% discount code okay
and of course the idea here is to get a
funny moment where I become startled by
this thing toppling while I'm doing a
different story that's sort of the dream
scenario that a lot of people in the
audience are probably hoping for Pat's
hoping for that scenario and we'll see
if it ultimately happened so patreon.com
slash david pakman show anybody can
participate okay for every two patrons I
will be playing a piece here I will be
describing what I am doing and Pat is
going to be reading the names of the
patrons for whom we are playing pieces
today right to the best of my abilities
so baby hard some of these names are a
little bit complex and please note don't
let's not do any new Pat scandals as a
result of this okay Pat let's switch
over to our tight shot on the a Jenga a
somewhat tight shot anyway and give me
the first two names and I am going to
play a piece first we have Rob mendoza
and raymond bond okay thank you to both
of you my strategy is usually to just
find really loose pieces that are in
there here is one and I'm gonna lean
around and just very very carefully pull
this piece out and very very little
motion there as you can see steady hands
in at Wharton they told me I had the
steadiest hands actually okay let's get
give me the next two names we have and
you're keeping track of the number of
moves right we're up to one so far very
good we have Brad King and Tim white
Brad King and Tim white let's see if I
can find I think it makes sense to
alternate between the centerpieces and
the side pieces already some of these
are very very tight here is a very loose
one here we go and this is of course
move
- oh boy this is already not going
particularly well we're getting a lot of
jitter here alright that is move number
two give me the next two names Pat now
if Kristen Barnet and Steven Nichols
very good here is a very loose piece and
I'm going to be able to move that easily
that is number three okay let's keep it
going
crystal Sutliff and Fred Lynott oh all
right now it's gonna get a little dicey
er here because we are starting to get
oh there's a loose piece let's see if I
can pull that out carefully very very
carefully ooh
there is wow that was almost a problem
and we are close there four moves at
this point all right let's give me the
give me the next two names yeah Yuri
Russell chalky and Andrew Hillard all
right for Yuri and Andrew I'm going to
try to go with a middle piece which is
really a big deal I hope that you
appreciate me doing that and it is just
not happening those middle pieces are
not releasing Pat and I am a little bit
worried about that because I think down
the line here's one down the line that
could make or break this alright we are
up to five moves give me the next two
names please how about Jennifer King and
SG sumin all right let's see what we can
do for Jennifer oh I almost just toppled
the entire thing here we go and we are
up to six moves thank you Samba Tesh and
Nell Nell okay just a first I just want
like Madonna I was waiting for the last
name there let's see what else I can
pull here here we have one towards the
bottom we are up to seven moves Pat I
hope you're taking notes I'm putting on
a Jenga clinic here keep it going Chris
menorah and Austin Roberts all right
Chris and Austin I think I'm gonna do
something a little special for you and
by that I mean I'm not going to
deliberately knock the tower over we are
up to eight moves right now keep it
going
Mario Rodriguez can sell and Katy dish
very good very good thank you I like
that pronunciation here we go Danny
you're up to nine not oh the Pats
getting anxious here but we got to make
sure okay we are up to nine now okay
number ten will be Daniel Ryan day and
Karen Blake Robinson Daniel and Karen
let's see what I can do here
what can I move
this one is a little tight but I think
it's a good position to move boom we are
up to ten ten pieces have been moved so
far double digits
Courtney headwear and Kelly Noel all
right Courtney and Kelly let's see what
I can find here a lot of these are now
getting incredibly difficult Wow I'm
starting to run out of options and it's
getting very very top-heavy let me see
what I can do
oh I found one that is very loose right
here on the bottom very very loose oh
wow the entire tower almost just went
over am I allowed to make a small
adjustment to it I just did I think
adding a little context but we are up to
11 moves Pat give me the next two names
please
John Koster and Carlos Macias John and
Carlos let's see here is another piece
we are up to 12 I have now recreated
four full levels of the Jenga tower all
right Pat give me the next one last one
for today Oh Samuel Medina and William
Reece see I'm tempted to do this bottom
one right here but that is gonna really
destabilize the tower but I'm gonna do
it because it's very well positioned
1313 moves and I have successfully
gotten through all of today's without
this thing toppling thank you to the 26
people I can't really do the rest of the
show because I think even if I breathe
on this thing it's going to fall
thirteen Jenga pieces have moved and let
us all together pray that it doesn't
fall during the rest of the program
pretty good I mean we don't know what
we're doing but I like this so far I'm
very worried about that bottom piece
though yeah I know the entire thing is
now being held up by just one not
particularly well placed middle piece on
the bottom but that's it for today will
persevere we will pick it up soon
conduct with contributions at
patreon.com slash david pakman show